you must be Dana Dana yeah so interested
in a position yes yes have you been
applying around yeah I've had lots and
lots and lots of interviews I was just
over my resume I brought another so you
can I actually have a lot of experience
okay
well I noticed that you have you worked
for my collection
yes they're a big rival and they
sometimes we are afraid that they have
stolen property is that right
well that's it's in the courts right now
so it's not something that we're we're
openly saying I would I would like you
to keep that sort of under wraps if
possible but yeah my collection well my
question is how long were you were you
there because I didn't when I guess it
said oh okay yeah
not long at all I actually worked on a
very focused project there oh I didn't
get it what was it
intelligence so are you indeed applying
are you but you
if you have a chance to talk to HR yet
our our procedures because I want to
make sure that we're on the same page
Robert you're four o'clock I can hold it
for just a minute I need to finish up
with Lissa can we do that gum what I
think maybe we should that's that's just
fine okay thank you so much it was a
lovely to meet you okay
pleasure